de vos compagnons vous envie vous
promener près de nier
on a juste dire que quand depuis le
début de ce défi derrière toutes sortes
de manifestations est ce qu'on a raison
de se complaire dans joêl tout étudiant
digne de ce nom devrait marcher guizot
1968 un peu partout dans le monde des
jeunes conteste le pouvoir établi et
réclament plus de liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
au québec la révolte est aussi culturel
la première salve est lancée au
quat'sous le théâtre de paul bus nous
[Musique]
parmi les cinq plus beaux souvenirs de
ma vie c'est la naissance de l'osstidcho
pourquoi le croit parce que c'est pas le
but sono qui étaient venus voir la
générale une semaine avant il y avait
trouvé ça tellement mauvais qu'il avait
dit je foule quand votre style chaud
vous pouvez le mettre où je pense
l'europe est flashé par excellence
on a trouvé un show à locales - yvon
deschamps était un des propriétaires du
catch où il a l'idée d'un spectacle
mêlant chansons et sketches avec robert
charlebois louise forestier mouffe et le
groupe jazz libre du québec on appeler
ça une chanson mayonnaise pour amener
les monologues d'yvon ou des petits
sketchs qu'on faisait ou un petit
monologue à gauche à droite ça plaît
dans les manufactures on chante des
chansons d'amour de man pour demain me
domaine
jones cédait vers le monde le succès est
instantané
après quelques semaines la petite salle
du quat'sous ne suffit plus l'institut
entreprend une tournée région des
croyants pourquoi cette époque là
d'après vous les gens soient gentils
rendu la touche à se préparer moi je dis
là depuis les années 60 2,63 et et ça
fait 1 espèce d'éjaculation formidable
non pas précoce en soit ça peut venir
[Musique]
que c'est la première fois qu'on
s'exprime est à peu près avec swing dans
notre langue québécoise et où des fuites
devrions jamais été dit a mérité à faire
maths compris la nature galopante
c'est donc un bon repas pendant que le
ch'ti choo fait danser le québec en
joual une quinzaine de comédienne
apprivoise le texte des bains soeur les
actrices ne veulent pas jouer dedans
parce que ses clients s'étaient créés en
joual à l'époque on jouait en français
de france au théâtre ou à peu près quand
la comédie un lit le texte de michel
tremblay
si le coup de foudre je lis cette pièce
je suis bouleversée je pleure je ris ge
chamba liste un milieu que je connais
donc je viens mais j'ai de 7h et 12h la
première des bébés seraient présentés en
ou hors saison car on craint l'échec et
c'est plutôt accueilli comme un deuxième
coup de tonnerre dans un québec en
pleine révolution pas toujours si
tranquille parce que c'est une
impression vraiment de jouer c'est si
réaliste que ça ou de vous a baissé un
peu je sais pas non on n'est ni de
s'abaisser bien parler le joual ça vous
choquer prénom ça me choque pas plus que
quand je vais à permis que je vends une
pièce à l'époque même jouer en argot à
new york joslyn dont l'angleterre jouant
en cockney chaque pays a son un bon ben
alors pourquoi pas un autre et le
langage de jouels de tremblay avait des
moments très peu et y est très beau très
très touchant
les humanitaires médecins du monde à
part ton école mon mari ne voudriez vous
avez vous vu l'institut oui bien sûr
j'ai tellement aimé j'ai adoré là aussi
ça s'est joué avec leur caste et jouer
avec les langages de la nouvelle
génération qui parlait aussi joal et là
aussi on se reconnaissaient courrier
[Musique]